[Music]
in january 2021
a mob occupied the u.s capitol seeking
to overturn the results of the
presidential election
this was a call to duty for america's
educators
while the capital attack was
precipitated by former president trump's
caustic lies
the poisonous polarization are reflected
can be traced
to weakness in the nation's civic
foundation
just a fraction of americans can name
the three branches of government
or pass the nation's citizenship test
most republicans
thought trump's 2016 presidential
election victory was fair
but that his 2020 defeat wasn't more
than 90 percent of democrats
said joe biden's 2020 election was fair
but nearly half
said hillary clinton's 2016 defeat
wasn't
democracy doesn't work if voters only
trust elections
when their side carries the this is a
test of our civic medal
our schools and colleges have a crucial
role to play
in helping us pass that test
do you think it's a problem that most
americans can't pass the nation's
citizenship test
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos
from aei